[Music]
on this friday night fighting to escape
russia's clutches
ukraine's bid to join the eu gains
momentum
we want them
to live with us the european dream what
the organization now wants from the
war-torn nation
women out of the office and hoping to
keep it that way there's a high level of
burnout their battle for a better
work-life balance
feeling the heat we need to take
precautions about the climate change
predictions of the summer ahead
and shooting stars these are memories
for a lifetime the pride and joy of
vaughn ontario joins an elite club in
the nba
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight bara nasser
good evening to you and thank you for
joining us
it has been a contentious issue for
years but today the european union
finally gave its blessing for ukraine
and its neighbor moldova to become
candidates to join the bloc
four days after russian troops invaded
in february ukraine's president asked to
urgently join the european union just
four days later moldova which shares a
border with ukraine also applied
now nearly four months later the eu's
recommendation is a significant step but
it is only the first in a process that
usually takes years and membership isn't
guaranteed
as jackson proskow explains in our top
story tonight the recommendation is a
symbolic boost to ukraine as it
struggles to push back russia
each day brings fresh horrors to ukraine
this was the aftermath of a missile
strike on a building sheltering
civilians
while near kiev war crimes investigators
explored new evidence of alleged russian
atrocities you've got all the hallmarks
of
a chain of command from the ground
crimes to
putin himself it all serves to
strengthen western resolve to do more
yes ukraine should be welcomed as a
candidate country in brussels the eu
took the next big step moving ukraine
and moldova to the status of candidate
countries further distancing them from
russia's orbit we all know that
ukrainians are ready to die for the
european perspective
we want them
to live with us the european dream
it's not the fast track ukraine had
hoped for
first the eu wants the besieged nation
to take action on corruption and
oligarchs full membership will require
unanimous approval of members and could
be years perhaps a decade away
yet on the streets of kiev there is
relief
it will simply give a signal to russia
that we are part of the european family
and we will not be with them she says
the option you meet vladimir putin's
immediate response defiance
the european union has completely lost
its political sovereignty he said
warning the world will never return to
its pre-war normal hello
in a sign of that new normal british
prime minister boris johnson paid a
second surprise visit to keem assuring
president vladimir zelinsky of support
for the long haul we
are with you to give you
the strategic endurance
that you will need
as the war nears a stalemate it's clear
ukraine faces an arduous journey both to
repel russia's invasion and earn the
status and protection it desires in the
west
jackson prosco global news
wikileaks founder julian assange is one
step closer to being extradited to the
united states where he faces spying
charges
the british government has approved the
order which is a major turning point in
the decade-long saga
it was sparked by the 2010 publication
of almost half a million u.s military
documents relating to the wars in iraq
and afghanistan assange is facing trial
on 17 charges of espionage and one
charge of computer misuse wikileaks says
it will appeal the decisions supporters
of assange say he was acting as a
journalist and is entitled to freedom of
speech under the first amendment
a retired priest is facing a charge of
indecent assault in connection with a
decades-long investigation into a former
manitoba residential school
rcmp say 92-year-old arthur moss was
arrested and charged yesterday he's
accused of assaulting a ten-year-old
girl more than 50 years ago at the fort
alexander residential school just north
of winnipeg police say the woman came
forward in 2010 with her claim and has
stood firm in speaking out about what
happened to her
this arrest is a culmination of a decade
of work by rcmp investigators who would
not have been able to bring this to a
conclusion
without the incredible bravery of the
victims and witnesses who were willing
to relive past trauma and speak about
what took place
more than 80 investigators worked on the
case contacting more than 700 people
across north america
in a search for witnesses and victims
the investigation is finished but if any
other potential victims come forward
police will follow up moss is scheduled
to appear in court next month
and a 24-hour crisis line is available
to support residential school survivors
it's toll-free and you can speak in
confidence the number is 1-800-7
the head of canada's most influential
first nations organization is facing
questions about her leadership following
allegations of harassment and bullying
assembly of first nations national chief
roseanne archibald says she welcomes an
investigation and in fact she wants it
to go even further by looking into
conduct at the afn itself
in a statement archibald says she has
been undermined discredited and attacked
in her efforts to clean up the afn which
she accused of mounting smear campaigns
against her she says an investigation
will help identify the toxicity within
the organization and bring about healing
and a cultural shift that is critically
needed
in the u.s kids under five are one step
closer to getting a first dose of the
covid19 vaccine
today the u.s food and drug
administration authorized the shots for
infants and preschoolers which means
vaccinations could begin next week
roughly 18 million kids in the u.s are
eligible it's been about a year and a
half since vaccines first became
available to adults in the united states
the centers for disease control and
prevention is expected to give its
approval this weekend
canada's national advisory committee on
immunizations or nasi has largely
followed the u.s fda in covid vaccine
approvals
flexible working arrangements have been
a lifeline to women especially mothers
during the pandemic as they balance home
and work responsibilities and the change
has led to a shift a new survey shows
nearly half of canadian women would
rather quit their jobs than go into the
office five days a week as heather urex
west explains advocates say the results
should be a wake-up call for employers
and government
for most of her career as an oncology
nurse joanne nuedek has worked on the
front lines at calgary's tom baker
cancer center but recently the mother of
five decided to make a change over the
last couple years there's been some life
changes and the pandemic and a bit of
soul-searching craving more flexibility
for her life and her family nuedek has
cut back on her hours as a nurse
focusing instead on work with a local
women's group a position that allows her
to work from home and i really love that
flexibility of working from home and and
running events still keeping my finger
in the pot as a nurse and so working
casual just one two days a week there's
a high level of burnout and again with
all those increased responsibilities at
home i think women are really feeling it
a new survey conducted by the prosperity
project has found that since the
pandemic the number of women employed
full time has declined but among those
who are working the research found that
73 percent would prefer to work from
home all or most of the time with a
quarter of respondents saying doing so
would help them better balance their
household responsibilities a number that
rose to more than 60 percent among those
with children under 12 and women who
were a visible minority and almost half
45 percent indicated that they would
quit their job if they were asked to
return to the office five days a week
the good news is that since the pandemic
and with a tight labor market work from
home and hybrid work arrangements are
becoming the norm but i think it's also
important to remember that these
flexible models hybrid models supports
for
women to work gender diverse people to
work don't apply to all sectors
especially those caregiving jobs the
world needed most during the pandemic
sectors that rely on often racialized
women and continue to offer lower pay
the gender pay gaps are increasing the
income gaps are increasing and you know
they're still affecting marginalized
women and racialized women and women
with disabilities heavily a call to
action for more support and creative
solutions during this period of recovery
heather urex west global news calgary
monkey pox cases are growing worldwide
but even as health officials say the
risk to the public is still low a new
survey finds the disease has canadians
concerned ipso's polling done
exclusively for global news finds more
than half of canadians 55 percent have
concerns about the spread of monkey pox
in our country however two-thirds say
they are confident canadian officials
are working quickly enough to contain it
now as we saw with kovid scientists are
learning more every day about the spread
jamie morocco has the latest on what you
need to know about the virus and a
warning some may find the images
disturbing
i was hearing about monkey pucks for
weeks before there were any confirmed
cases in canada toronto bathhouse clerk
graham lamb says the tight-knit
community he works in was quick to react
educating patrons and offering vaccines
bathhouse workers and bath house
customers are being really proactive in
taking some of the steps that are
available to us in ontario there have
been 21 confirmed cases of the virus
alberta has seen four while bc has
recorded two the majority 141 have been
in quebec all the patients are men the
most precautionary thing to do to
protect
against transmission is to be isolated
until all your scabs have healed and
fallen off and your skin is beginning to
reform underneath this means missing
weeks of work for some that leave is
unpaid in a letter to canada's health
minister 48 community groups called for
financial assistance for those impacted
the world health organization meantime
is preparing to hold an emergency
meeting on the virus next week still
experts say catching monkey pox which
happens through close prolonged personal
contact isn't as easy as contracting
covet 19. the level of risk
let's say compared to omicron is very
very small the average person will
unlikely be exposed to monkey box lamb
says preemptive protection will continue
to be paramount
making it more broadly available before
you know for sure that you've been in
contact is just an easy way to help
limit the risk and head off the spread
jamie morocco global news toronto
rising temperatures and rising anxiety
coming up the worries about what's in
the forecast for this summer
everest base camp is going to be moved
lower down the world's highest mountain
nepal's government says global warming
and a growing human footprint are making
the current site too dangerous and
unstable the camp is located on the
kumbu glacier which at 5
300 meters is now melting and climbers
say crevices are appearing while they
sleep
to avoid any fatal accidents the new
camp will be set up 200 to 400 meters
lower
and what nepal is experiencing is part
of the larger issue affecting every
living thing on earth the changing
climate
extreme weather is irreversibly altering
parts of the world
in just the past 24 hours parts of
canada have faced intense lightning
flooding and extreme heat
now parts of the northern hemisphere are
seeing more dangerously high
temperatures and as abigail beeman
reports not everyone is prepared
marathon runners in winnipeg are gearing
up for a potentially risky race with
temperatures expected to be a dozen
degrees higher than normal i am not
happy about that it's going to be a slow
day i'm just going to have to pace
myself out whether it's 36 or 10 degrees
i'm going to run anyways i was told
there was one guy giving out beers i'll
probably skip that one
there's already been plenty of wild
weather this spring flooding in calgary
a deadly storm in ontario and quebec
we're nearing the one-year anniversary
of the heat dome in british columbia
which killed 619 people i think we've
learned that access to cool and clean
indoor air has to be a human right we
know that people who didn't have air
conditioning those who were elderly had
chronic diseases isolated were those who
suffered the highest mortality extreme
weather is a global problem this week
the u.s has seen devastating fires
floods tornadoes friday was the hottest
day of the year in the united kingdom
it's
mad the way things are going you need to
take precautions about the climate
change
sooner than later france saw 40 degrees
thursday with temperatures not expected
to peak until saturday we have iced
water
so we froze the water overnight
and then that will keep us going today
but we want to rest because we're
walking up the eiffel tower
wildfires in spain 80 centimeters of
rain in china flash flooding killed 16
people in india we used to think this
thing occurred in bangladesh and
botswana and bolivia well it's occurring
in burlington and brandon and burnaby
with summer just around the corner dave
phillips says we should brace for a
hotter than normal season at home and
while he doesn't think it will be as
dangerously record-breaking as last year
we shouldn't forget dress rehearsal of
what we're going to see more years in
the future it may be another 10 or 15
years before you see a scorcher of an
episode that we saw last year
but it won't be the last one more ac
only burning more fossil fuels phillips
calls it an ugly circuit abigail beeman
global news ottawa
filipino military officials say two
militants accused of beheading two
canadians have finally surrendered
robert hall and john ridsdel were
abducted by abu sayyaf gunmen along with
a norwegian and a filipino from a marina
on samal island nearly seven years ago
and taken to a jungle camp hall and
ridsdel were later beheaded after the
deadline for ransom payment passed two
other hostages were eventually freed at
the time prime minister justin trudeau
said he was horrified by the killings
but he affirmed canada's refusal to pay
ransoms it's believed the same militants
are also responsible for the 2017
beheading of a german tourist
westjet re-routing just ahead the
potential impacts as the airline focuses
on the west
the liberals have tabled a bill seeking
to eliminate self-induced extreme
intoxication as a legal defense for
violent crimes
bill c-28 would create new language in
the criminal code to cover a person who
commits a violent crime while extremely
intoxicated by drugs in a controversial
decision last month canada's top court
ruled the previous wording of the law
which had eliminated self-induced
intoxication as a defense was
unconstitutional
the decision by westjet to refocus its
roots and fleet back to its roots in
western canada is being met with mixed
reaction aviation experts expect westjet
to remove services in the toronto
montreal and ottawa triangle and as nitu
garcia reports there are wider fears
about what it could mean for the future
of airfares and air travel in this
country
westjet's operations are about to become
more true to its name focusing its fleet
on western canada if the idea takes off
it could mean savings for passengers you
pay for what you get it's about time
we need low cost carriers here the
airline says half of its new 30 boeing
787 max aircraft will join the fleet
this year and it plans to gradually
reposition the existing wide-body
dreamliner fleet to western canada where
its most popular routes are add more
non-stop direct flights between western
canadian communities while maintaining a
presence in eastern provinces but the
airline hasn't established exactly what
it means for routes and prices it's
clear air canada dominates the east and
easterners for some reason have a
wedding or a love affair with air canada
and i think westjet finds it very
difficult to penetrate that market
for the airlines that are left traveling
to those destinations
they can easily raise
fares
and that's not good for the consumer
everybody is looking for a deal
now from the west to the east
there'll be no deals
it'll be just full fair it'll be fairs
that people cannot afford
but industry experts say while the
pandemic has taken its toll westjet's
biggest issue is complexity operating
multiple aircraft types and after buying
ultra low cost carrier swoop if you look
at the most successful airlines in the
planet from a profitability standpoint
they're probably southwest and and
someone like ryanair and what do they
have in common they only have one
aircraft type they only fly the 737 so
every pilot can fly every airplane which
is how westjet once operated i think
it's great i think westjet needs to
compete a little bit in the low fare
department especially with the likes of
flare and swoop that are taking over so
amid high fuel prices and economic
uncertainty as demand recovers in a
vastly different landscape for this
airline its strategy is going back to
the future nitu garcia global news
that's global national for this friday
night i'm farin asser and i want to
thank you so much for spending part of
your evening with us tonight's your
canada is the halifax skyline we love
seeing your canada so please keep
sending us those photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and each other good night